[Musique]
Dieu merci, j'ai été bon
personnes M. Marco José Vanessa son
enfants une famille assez réceptive
avec moi ça vraiment
tu es dans mes prières chaque jour
parce que super reconnaissant à lui et à lui
l'État de New York parce que c'est comme ça
la réception qu'ils nous ont faite ce jour-là
c'était très confortable pour moi
Et mes proches Regarde, je m'en vais
Non, je t'aiderai à un moment donné. Laisse-moi
je me stabilise je t'aide
ces papiers on fait autre chose
mais qu'ils viennent comme ça
Non non je ne le recommande plus
nous avons opté pour une meilleure qualité pour de
la vie pour le bébé et pour nous
plus que tout pour elle Oh oui oui nous avons
obtenu de l'aide et ils nous ont envoyé
beaucoup d'annonces et que nous allons
aux adresses où ils donnent comme
Cours d'anglais et autres types d'aide
[Musique]